[music playing]
NEIL DEGRASSE
TYSON: It used to be
hard to keep food from
spoiling in the summertime.
There was a person
called the ice man.
He would come to your house and
sell you a big block of ice.
You'd keep it in
something called
an ice box, to
preserve the kinds
of food that spoil quickly.
But that was a drag because
the ice kept melting.
It would drip all
over the floor.
So somebody thought up
another way to keep food cold.
It was a gas-powered
system that used ammonia
or sulfur dioxide as a coolant.
No more lugging blocks of ice.
What could be bad about that?
The chemicals were
not only poisonous,
they smelled terrible.
And there were leaks.
A substitute coolant
was badly needed.
One that would circulate inside
the refrigerator, but would not
poison anyone if the
refrigerator leaked.
Or pose a danger if it
was sent to the junkyard.
Something that
wouldn't make you sick.
Wouldn't burn your
eyes or attract bugs.
Or even bother the cat.
But in all of nature, no such
material seemed to exist.
So chemists in the United States
invented a class of molecules.
Little collections
of even tinier things
called atoms that had never
existed on Earth before.
They call them
chlorofluorocarbons, or CFCs,
Because they were made up of one
or more carbon atoms and some
chlorine and/or fluorine atoms.
These new molecules
were wildly successful.
Far exceeding the expectations
of their inventors.
Not only did CFCs become the
chief coolant in refrigerators,
but also in air conditioners.
There were so many things
you could do with CFCs.
People used them to propel great
fluffy mounds of shaving cream.
And to protect your
hair from wind and rain.
It was also the
propellant that made
fire extinguishers and spray
paint cans so much fun.
It was good for foam
insulation, industrial solvents,
and cleansing agents.
The most famous brand
name of these chemicals
was freon, a
trademark of DuPont.
It was used for
decades and no harm
ever seemed to come from it.
Safe as safe could
be, everyone figured.
Until in the early 1970s,
two atmospheric chemists
at the University
of California Irvine
were studying
Earth's atmosphere.
Mario Molina was a
Mexican immigrant,
a young laser chemist.
Sherwood Rowland was a
chemical kineticist--
someone who studied the
motions of molecules and gases
under varying conditions.
He was from a
small town in Ohio.
Molina wanted to
grow as a scientist.
He was looking
for a project that
would take him as far
from his previous research
experience as possible.
He wondered, what happens
to those freon molecules
when they leak out of
the air conditioner?
This was a time when
the Apollo astronauts
were still making regularly
scheduled trips to the moon.
And NASA was contemplating
weekly launches
of a space shuttle.
Would all that burning
rocket fuel pose
a danger to the stratosphere--
that place where
Earth's atmosphere
meets the blackness of space?
And this is how science
works a lot of the time.
You set out to solve
one problem and you
happen on a
completely different,
unexpected phenomena.
Those wonderfully
inert, harmless CFCs,
the magic molecules of
shaving cream and hairspray,
didn't simply vanish when
we were done with them.
They had an afterlife
at the edge of space,
where they accumulated
in the trillions.
They were silently congregating
high above the Earth
and they were up to no good.
Molina and Roland were alarmed
to discover that the CFCs had
thinned the protective layer
that shielded us from the sun's
harmful ultraviolet radiation.
And it was getting
worse all the time.
When UV light hits
a CFC molecule,
it strips away the
chlorine atoms.
Once that happens, the
chlorine atoms start devouring
the precious ozone molecules.
It wasn't until our planet
developed an ozone layer,
about two and a half
billion years ago,
that it was safe for life to
leave the ocean for the land.
A single chlorine
atom can destroy
100,000 ozone molecules.